monsieur le ministre le Sénat est saisi
donc du projet de loi portant
transposition de l'accord national
interprofessionnel relatif au partage de
la valeur au sein de l'entreprise adopté
par l'Assemblée nationale le 29 juin
dernier après engagement de la procédure
accélérée notre commission devrait
l'examiner dès la semaine prochaine
c'est très rapide he mercredi 11 octobre
avant son passage en séance qui pourrait
intervenir les mardis 17 et mercredi 18
octobre si la Conférence des présidents
ont décidé ainsi elle se réunit ce
soir je rappelle que chemine en
parallèle à l'Assemblée nationale un
autre texte sur le travail le projet de
loi pour le plein emploi adopté par le
Sénat le 11 juillet dernier il est donc
probable que des commissions mixtes
paritaires soi convoqué au cours des
prochaines semaines afin d'essayer
d'élaborer une version commune de chacun
de ces deux textes monsieur le ministre
je vais vous laisser la parole pour un
propos introductif puis notre rapporteur
Frédéric puissard et les autres
commissaires par la suite qui le
souhaiteront vous interrogeront sur les
différents points de ce texte monsieur
le ministre vous avez la parole merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Madame la rapporteur générale
madame la la rapporteur d'abord
permettez-moi monsieur le Président
Madame la rapporteur générale de de vous
féliciter pour votre élection et
réélection et à travers cette élection
et cette réélection féliciter l'ensemble
des des sénatrices et des sénateurs qui
ont été élus ou réélus à l'occasion des
des dernières élections sénatoriales et
et vous dire aussi le le plaisir que
j'ai à vous retrouver pour ce premier
texte je je sais que le calendrier est
extrêmement serré vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président il y a une
explication à cela et cela ne signifie
pas que ça rend les choses faciles mais
nous avons la la volonté et en écho à
celle des partenaires sociaux
signataires de de l'accord
interprofessionnel que ce textte puisse
entrer en vigueur au 1er janvier 2024 et
dans ce cas-là avec quelques textes
d'application nécessaire le temps nous
est compté chaque semaine compte pour
pouvoir prendre toutes les dispositions
permettant cette entrée en vigueur au
1er janvier 2024 nous nous sommes là
réunis autour d'un texte qui comme vous
l'avez dit a été adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale avec une méthode d'adoption de
de ce texte à l'Assemblée qui a été
extrêmement respectueuse de l'accord tel
qu'il a été signé par les les trois
organisations patronales représentatives
et quatre des cinq organisations
syndicales représentatives en terme de
méthode je le dis parce que cela
expliquera peut-être les positions que
j'aurais à prendre à l'occasion du du
débat et de l'examen du texte en séance
nous avons avec l'ensemble de mon équipe
et et donc au nom du gouvernement
veillez à ce que chaque amendement
déposé par le Gouvernement et chaque
disposition proposée par les les députés
par par voie d'amendement soit
conditionné il n'y a pas d'autres mot en
tout cas subordonné à un accord unanime
des SEP organisations patronal et
syndical signataire de de cet accord
c'était pour nous la seule manière
d'assurer à la fois l'intégralité et et
la fidélité de de la transposition et de
considérer que si des dispositions non
prévues ou non explicitement indiqué
dans l'accord devait être ajouté au
texte de transposition cela ne pouvait
pas se faire sans l'accord de celles et
ceux qui avaient construit ce texte
construit cet accord interprofessionnel
et donc c'est avec cette méthode que que
nous l'avons fait ce texte nous le
soutenons évidemment nous le défendons
car il s'inscrit dans la droite ligne
des différents textes que nous avons
portés en matière d'accompagnement de
l'intéressement et de la participation
je pense à la loi PCT de 2019 qui a
simplifié la mise en place des accords
d'intéressement et de participation dans
les PME en avec une att activité du
régime social de ces dispositifs
renforcés pour les petites entreprises
je pense aussi au aux mesures d'urgence
pour la protection du pouvoir d'achat
que nous avons examiné en juillet 2022
et qui ont fait l'objet d'une
publication de la loi publiée le 16 août
2022 qui s'inscrit aussi dans cette
droit de ligne avec le fait de faciliter
davantage le recours à l'intéressement
dans les PME d'instaurer une nouvelle
prime de de partage de la valeur nous
avions déjà travaillé avec Madame la
rapporteur sur cette partie du texte au
au bonc la la prime de partage de la
valeur prime exceptionnel de pouvoir
d'achat antiellement dénommé a bénéficié
en en 2022 à plus de 5,5 millions de
salariés pour un mon un montant total de
de près de 4,4 milliards d'euros c'est
donc un bon outil dont les entreprises
se sont saisies et contrairement à ce
que l'on pouvait imaginer et
contrairement même à ce qui été craint
par certains lorsque la prime a été
créée le le montant moyen de de la prime
est plus important dans les petites que
dans les grandes entreprises ce qui
démontre aussi le l'attrait de ce
dispositif pour des entreprises n'ayant
pas forcément la taille ou ne ne
considérant pas la taille nécessaire
pour mettre en place des dispositifs
peut-être plus complexes de manière
générale les dispositifs de partage de
la valeur fonctionnent bien dans notre
pays puisqu'en 2020 dans les entreprises
de plus de de 10 salariés nous avions
une moyenne tout tout dispositif
confondu de 2440 € et un total de 19
milliards d'euros au niveau national en
en terme de dispositif de de partage de
la
valeur nous nous avons voulu donc porter
cet accord et nous avons voulu le faire
euh le faire examiner et négocier par
les les partenaires sociaux à la fois en
soulignant les dispositifs existants
mais aussi en rappelant un certain
nombre de principes que les partenaires
sociaux ont repris et que le texte
reprend aussi sur le fait que ces
dispositifs de partage ne se substituent
pas au salaire et ne doivent pas se
substituer au salaire pour bien
différencier et ne pas nourrir de
confusion sur les différents éléments
constitutif constitutifs de la la
rémunération des salariés et d'ailleurs
parallèlement à à ces au développement
de ces dispositifs parallèlement aussi
aux discussions sur l'accord nous avons
un ensemble d'outils qui nous permettent
d'assurer une certaine dynamique des des
salaires dans dans le pays avec
notamment l'indexation du SMIC sur
l'inflation ce qui nous a amené à
différentes revalorisations successives
et une revalorisation globale en en
l'espace de presque 3 ans de 12,4 %
puisque c'est la revalorisation totale
du SMIC depuis janvier 2021 et nous
avons renforcé avec vous en 2022 les
obligations de négociation des branches
dès lors qu'un minima conventionnel de
la convention collective passe en
dessous du du niveau du SMIC donc nous
voulons aller plus loin plus loin en en
en transposant cet accord dans la loi et
en ayant comme objectif de développer
ces ces dispositifs d'intéressement et
de participation dans toutes les
entreprises y compris les entreprises de
moins 50 salaries c'est un point
important qui a justifié la la la
proposition de cet accord partenaires
sociaux les dispositifs je disais
marchent bien mais il marche mieux
aujourd'hui dans les grandes entreprises
que dans les petites pour les
dispositifs les plus classiques qui sont
l'intéressement et la participation à
titre d'exemple sur la seule
participation avec un cadre législatif
très particulier si 70 % des salariés
des entreprises de plus de plus de 100
salariés ont accès un dispositif de
participation ça n'est que 3 % des
entreprises de moins de 10 salariés et 6
% des entreprises entre 10 et 49
salariés d'où la nécessité d'avoir une
attention particulière sur cette strade
d'entreprise ainsi et sur la base de ces
différents constats nous avons saisi les
partenaires sociaux en septembre 2022
de ce projet d'accord et les discussions
les discussions se sont déroulées et de
manière conclusive puisque l'accord
interprofessionnel a été signé le 10
février 2023 par donc se des des
partenaires sociaux représentatifs les
les trois organisations patronales et
les quatre organisations syndical
suivante la CFDT la CFTC Force ouvrière
et la CFE CGC le projet de loi comporte
des mesures concrètes pour revaloriser
le travail et associer les salariés il y
a 23 articles je je ne vais évidemment
pas tous les détails mais simplement en
préciser quelques uns d'abord pour
souligner l'importance que les
partenaires sociaux signataires de
l'accord ont donné à la question des
classifications puisque vous le savez
les organisations doivent se réunir une
fois tous les 5 ans pour examiner la
nécessité de renégocier les
classification dans le cadre des
conventions collectives en matière de
rémunération et la pratique n'est pas
tout à fait au rendez-vous ainsi au 30
septembre 2023 il y a quelques jours 63
% des branches du secteur général
n'avaient pas révisé les grilles de
classification depuis plus de 5 ans 43 %
depuis plus de 10 ans et 9 % depuis plus
de 20 ans et donc il y a un vrai travail
à faire sur les classifications pour
éviter d'avoir des des carrières qui
soient trop plates en terme de
rémunération par un simple alignement
des premiers niveaux conventionnels sur
les revalorisations du SMIC et donc le
premier axe du projet de loi consiste à
créer une obligation d'engager la
négociation d'ici au 31 décembre 2023
pour les branches en vue de l'examen de
la nécessité de réviser les
classifications pour les branches
n'ayant pas procédé à cet examen depuis
depuis 5 ans c'est donc un dispositif
important avec une date butoire
d'ouverture de la négociation non pas de
de conclusion mais qui nous paraît tout
à fait essentiel pour que la question
des classification soit enfin abordé et
et bien abordé si vous me permettez de
le dire ainsi ensuite le projet de loi
permet de développer des dispositifs qui
existent en matière de partage de la
valeur en particulier dans les petites
et moyennes entreprises avec la volonté
de faciliter le développement de la
participation dans les entreprises de
moins de 50 salariés celles qui ne sont
pas soumises à l'obligation de mise en
place du dispositif par la négociation
par accord de Bran ou par accord
d'entreprise de formule dérogatoire à la
formule légale de participation puisque
la formule actuelle consiste constitue
parfois un frein au développement du
partage de la valeur dans ces
entreprises donc le texte permet de
négocier des formules de participation
dérogatoire à la formule légale pouant
mener un résultat plus favorable mais
aussi moins favorable que celui obtenu
avec la formule légale dans les
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés et
donc avec plus de souplesse pour
développement de ces dispositifs
parallèlement mais je l'ai dit l'article
2A a introduit dans le texte le principe
de non substitution comme une forme de
rappel pour que le texte soit aussi
équilibré que l'accord qui avait été
conclu il y a trois autres dispositions
que je souhaite sur lesquelles je
souhaite appeler votre attention la
première concerne les entreprises de 11
à 50 salariés qui auront jusqu'au 31
décembre 2023 pour mettre en place un
dispositif de partage de la valeur dès
lors qu'elles ont un bénéfice net fiscal
positif supérieur à 1 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires pendant 3 années consécutive
l'objectif est d'avoir un un outil qui
rende obligatoire ces dispositifs de
partage de la valeur lorsque les entre
entreprises sont durablement
bénéficiaires et l'Assemblée nationale à
la demande des partenaires sociaux
concernés et avec l'accord évidemment
les signataire à ajouter les structures
deéconomie sociale et solidaire bien que
n'ayant pas de bénéfice net fiscal nous
avons trouvé un dispositif qui permette
de les intégrer de les inclure dans
cette nouvelle obligation l'avancement
d'un an de l'entrée en vigueur de cette
disposition a été porté par le
rapporteur le député Louis Marguerite je
pense que cette disposition reste
proportionnée puisque les entreprises
peuvent satisfaire l'obligation par la
mise en place du seul dispositif de la
PPV mais je sais que ça peut faire
l'objet de de débat avec Madame la
rapporteur en particulier ensuite les
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés qui
sont soumises à l'obligation de mise en
place d'un dispositif de participation
auront jusqu'au 30 juin 2024 pour
négocier les conséquences en terme de
partage de la valeur dans les
entreprises en cas de bénéfice
exceptionnel la rédaction de l'article 5
du du projet de loi qui vous est soumis
est désormais sécurisé juridiquement
puisque nous avons repris les les
recommandations du du Conseil d'État
avec une négociation sur la définition
de l'augmentation exceptionnelle du
bénéfice je fais une parenthèse pour
dire que l'accord tel qu'il a été signé
par les partenaires sociaux renvoyait la
disposition la définition du caractère
exceptionnel du résultat à la seule
entreprise en l'occurrence au chef
d'entreprise nous étions convaincus que
cela serait frappé d'une forme
d'incompétence législative et nous
l'avons indiqué aux partenaires sociaux
mais nous avons malgré tout saisi le
Conseil d'État en vue de son examen en
section avec les dispositions stricto
sensu conforme à à laani euh évidemment
la section du Conseil d'État nous a
signalé la la difficulté nous avons
corrigé euh notre texte avant le passage
enassemblée générale je précise
évidemment que la correction a été faite
en plein accord avec les SEP partenaires
sociaux signataires et l'assemblée
générale a malgré tout formuler un avis
très réservé sur le sujet en nous
faisant des propositions des
recommandations de sécurisation qui ont
donné lieu à des amendements à
l'Assemblée nationale eux aussi
présentés avec l'accord de de chacun des
SEP partenaires sociaux enfin 3è deè
disposition sur lesquelles je souhaite
appeler votre attention l'exonération
fiscale applicable pour les salariés
dont la rémunération est inférieure à 3
SMIC sur la prime de partage de la
valeur sera prolongé jusqu'au 31
décembre 2026 dans les entreprises de
moins de 50 salariés enfin et pour en
terminer par par là le projet crée de
nouveaux outils pour permettre
d'améliorer l'action l'actionnariat
salarié et de rénover certains
dispositif qui existe ainsi le projet de
loi crée le plan de partage de la
valorisation de l'entreprise plan du
durée de 3 ans mise en place pour
l'ensemble des salariés et par accord
d'entreprise il permet au salariés de
bénéficier d'une prime dans le cas où la
valeur de l'entreprise a augmenté sur
les tris les trois années de la durée du
plan donc c'est un outil innovant
permettant aussi de participer à la fois
au partage de la valeur et de la
valorisation de l'entreprise mais aussi
de fidéliser des des personnels dans un
contexte parfois de de tension de
recrutement le projet de loi facilite
aussi l'utilisation de la prime de
partage de la valeur ainsi les
entreprises pourront par exemple verser
jusqu'à deux primes par an au lieu d'une
seule et elle pourra être versée sur un
plan d'épargne salarial pour permettre
au salariés de bénéficier d'une d'une
exonération fiscale pour les sommes
bloquées et enfin le projet doit
développe l' l'actionnariat salariés je
je l'ai évoqué à la fois par l'ouverture
d'une plus grande portion du capital aux
salariesés actionnaires avec
l'augmentation des plafonds de versement
d'action gratuit par la promotion d'une
épargne verte solidaire et responsable
des plans d'épargne d'entreprise et
retraite d'entreprise puisqu'il y aura
une obligation de proposer au moins un
fond qui finance la transition
écologique et sociale et enfin par
l'amélioration de la gouvernance des
fonds d'actionnariat salariés pour plus
de de transparence tous les autres
articles sont des articles de
simplification extrêmement technique sur
lesquels je ne reviens pas voilà
monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur ce que je pouvais dire pour
présenter le texte je ne reviens pas sur
la la méthode que que j'ai évoqué je
souhaite évidemment que ce texte puisse
continuer à a cheminer et que rapidement
cet accord puisse avoir toute la force
législative nécessaire pour son entrée
en vigueur merci monsieur le ministre je
donne tout de suite la parole à notre
rapporteur Frédéric puissa merci
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur le
le ministre pour ses pour ses propos
introductifs euh et et pour faire le
lien avec votre dernière phrase avant de
vous poser quatre questions revenir
effectivement sur deux enjeux de
temporalité la première pour d'une part
vous faire part de notre inquiétude et
la deuxième nous faire part de votre de
notre satisfaction inquiétude nous
l'avons évoquer ensemble monsieur le
ministre et je pense que les groupes
d'opposition l'exprimeront également
nous sommes quand même sur un texte nous
comprenons parfaitement qu'il que nous
devions aller vite néanmoins je souhaite
quand même vous indiquer que nous avons
démarré les aud de ce texte sans que la
commission sociale ne soit constituée ce
qui fait qu'un certain nombre de
commissaires ont été privés des
auditions que nous avons dû faire d'une
part et que d'autre part nous n'avions
pas de président pour effectivement
organiser les choses donc très
honnêtement si on pouvait même si nous
sommes capables de tout comprendre on
s'aperçoit quand même que souvent
vitesse et précipitations ne font pas
bon ménage et si on pouvait davantage
poser les choses pour ce début de
mandature ça serait quand même une bonne
chose voilà pour notre inquiétude
s'agissant effectivement de notre
satisfaction et je je me permets du coup
d'énoncer un petit peu peu la façon dont
dont je je perçois ce texte et dont nous
percevons ce texte vous l'avez dit
monsieur le ministre vous avez demandé
aux partenaires sociaux d'engager des
discussion en septembre dernier dans un
contexte en septembre 2022 qui était un
contexte compliqué un contexte
effectivement d'enjeu de pouvoir d'achat
fort pour les salariés un contexte
d'incertitude aussi économique pour un
certain nombre d'entreprises et que ça
soit les os ou les OP chacun est parti à
reculon sur ces discussions or et c'est
une satisfaction dont je pense nous
pouvons tous être fiers ils y sont
arrivés ils sont arrivés à un accord
national
interprofessionnel et je dois dire que
dans ce cas-là j'ai souvent coutume de
dire que pardon du terme mais le cœur
nucléaire de l'entreprise ce sont les
salariés et les employeurs ce sont donc
les os et les OP qui le représentent et
que parfois le législateur doit pouvoir
s'effacer au profit d'accord national
interprofessionnel et c'est ce que je
vous proposerai dans ce texte pour
effectivement être vraiment basé sur
cette Annie et le respecter à la lettre
de façon à ce qu'on puisse respecter la
parole des partenaires sociaux et le
travail qui a été fait voilà sur les
propos introductifs maintenant quatre
questions sur la méthode monsieur le
ministre vous avez évoqué les travaux
qui ont été conduits par nos collègues
députés avec la possibilité en tout cas
vous leur avveit offert d'avoir des
allers-retours sur les amendements qui
étaient proposés avec les organisations
syndicales et les organisations
patronnales première question est-ce que
le Sénat sera logé à la même enseigne
est-ce que nous aurons la même
possibilité de façon à ce que nous
puissions effectivement être en phase
avec la parole des partenaires sociaux
deuxème question euh nous sommes
effectivement sur ce texte sur un
certain nombre d'articles et nous avons
eu l'occasion de de l'évoquer qui à la
fois relève du législatif et du
règlementaire alors on aura peut-être
quelques ajustements hein au cours de de
nos discussions en tout cas on
s'affairera à remettre les choses au bon
niveau pour qu'il y ait de la lisibilité
dans ces outils donc ma question est la
suivante est-ce que nous pourrions avoir
un calendrier s'agissant en l'occurrence
du réglementaire de ce qui pourrait être
mise en place et de la façon dont nous
pourront suivre cet accord national
interprofessionnel 3ème question qui
relève effectivement d'un d'un
dispositif un peu particulier puisqu'il
s'agit effectivement du du Travail
Temporaire un certain nombre de règles
de distribution on été adapté pour le
travail temporaire le travail intérim
pour parler un langage qu'on qu'on
connaît mieux on a quand même eu un
certain nombre de retours en
l'occurrence des représentants du
travail temporaire pour nous indiquer
que nous n'allions pas assez loin sur
ces dispositifs donc ma question est-ce
qu'effectivement on peut adapter cet
outil sachant qu'on est dans le respect
de la ni hein puisque c'est bien un
point qui avait été évoqué mais il
semblerait quand même que ça ne se ça ne
satisfasse pas les les représentants de
l'intérim et enfin ma dernière question
qui concerne l'économie sociale et
solidaire vous en avez parlé monsieur le
ministre nous nous sommes rencontrés sur
ce sujet-là nous savons que le champ de
l'esss est un champ qui est très vaste
mais nous savons aussi que c'est un
champ qui concerne aussi des
collectivités locales et que souvent le
champ de l'esss est soumis à des
subventions des collectivités locales
alors nous sommes tous effectivement
très favorables he à ce que le SS puisse
bénéficier un d'outil de de
participation et et d'intéressement de
façon dérogatoire mais nous sommes aussi
tous attachés à ce qu'il n'y ait pas de
pression sur les collectivités pour
qu'on puisse effectivement arriver à des
résultats exceptionnels qui du coup
enclencheraient ces primes de
participation alors on avait vu ensemble
une possibilité de pouvoir aménager cet
article de sorte que nous ne soyons pas
en pression vis-à-vis des collectivités
et j'aurais souhaité avoir votre point
de vue sur le
sujet merci Frédéric monsieur le
ministre c'est à vous merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur sur la question du calendrier
je je l'ai dit au début de mon propos
liminire je je l'entends bien nous avons
une contrainte que j'ai évoqué qui est
la la nécessité vu les dates négociées
par les parten sociaux d'aller vite pour
leur permettre notamment pour ce qui
concerne les obligations d'ouverture de
négociation avant le 31 décembre 2023 de
le faire aussi sur la la base d'un texte
qui a été publié il y a une autre
difficulté que que je n'ai pas évoqué
mais qui est propre au Parlement à
chaque début de de session c'est
l'absence de de créneaux nombreux en
terme de disponibilité du fait des
textes budgétaires qui doivent arriver
et qui vont très rapidement à
l'Assemblée comme comme au Sénat occuper
beaucoup du temps je dis ça en me disant
aussi qu'à l'Assemblée ça peut parfois
aller plus vite dans la configuration
que l'on connaît
mais n'empêche qu'au Sénat vous aurez la
tout toute la possibilité de ter des des
textes financiers et que ça vient
occuper un certain nombre de semaines et
j'en suis j'en suis désolé sur la la
question des contraintes temporaires de
temp temporel pardon mais nous devons
nous devons malheureusement composer
avec sur les les sujets que vous avez
évoqué et les quatre questions j'ai
envie de répondre quatre fois oui parce
que sur la question de la méthode bien
évidemment je je je l'ai dit chaque avis
que je seraai amené à donner sur des
amendements déposés par les les
sénateurs sera conditionné pour les avis
favorables à à l'accord des des des SEP
partenaires sociaux et et chaque
amendement que je serais éventuellement
amené à à déposer au nom du gouvernement
le sera aussi et et pour que il y ait
une parfaite compréhension je crois de
de cette de cette mécanique là ça
nécessite qu'il y ait des liens très
étroits avec vous-même comme rapporteur
avec l'ensemble des sénateurs qui qui le
souhaitent pour bien que chacun sache
pourquoi nous prenons nous donnons un
avis favorable à un amendement et pas et
pas à un autre et et de la même manière
c'est quand vous évoquez le le travail
temporaire oui dès lors que les
partenaires sociaux sont d'accord et et
oui dès lors qu'il y a la la possibilité
de tenir compte des de l'avis du Conseil
d'État notamment sur un certain nombre
de risques que ce même conseil avait
pointé mais avec ces deux nuances là la
nuance de méthode que j'observe depuis
le début de l'examen du texte au
Parlement et cette question des des avis
il n'y a pas de pas de difficulté pour
qu'on puisse avancer sur la question de
le SS nous l'avons effectivement évoqué
ensemble depuis notre notre rencontre il
y a y a quelques jours j'allais dire
quelques heures que c'était il y a de
jours jour nous avons commencé à
regarder nous avons une difficulté de
méthode mais que je vous propose
d'expertiser ensemble d'ici à la séance
qui est une disposons pas de données
consolidées sur le le total des
subventions perçues par les entreprises
en général et et de l' SS en particulier
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit de connaître
les subventions perçues de la part de
l'État des collectivités locales et de
la sécurité sociale puisque dans le
champ de l' SS il peut aussi y avoir un
certain nombre de subventions de de la
protection sociale donc je vous propose
qu'on continue à à l'expertiser comme
nous en étions convenu parce qu'on on
aurait une une difficulté peut-être
d'applicabilité de la mesure et et je
pense que ça n'est pas l'objectif que
que nous recherchons les uns et les
autres enfin sur la question du
législatif et du réglementaire je sais
les les réserves qui sont les votres sur
un certain nombre de dispositions
adoptées à l'Assemblée dont vous
considérez qu'elle relève du du
réglementaire ça me donne l'occasion de
de dire que certaines dispositions
adoptées par l'Assemblée peuvent
effectivement être traité par voie
réglementaire et que d'autres peuvent
apparaître comme déjà satisfaites par le
droit existant je pense à l'article 2A
sur le principe de non substitution qui
est prévu de manière explicite dans le
code du travail mais nous savons aussi
que les signataires de l'accord sont
attachés au fait que le projet de loi
tel que vous l'adopterez si vous le
souhaitez soit aussi représentatif de
l'équilibre de l'accord qu'ils ont
trouvé d'où le rappel qui avait été fait
à l'article 2A tous les textes
réglementaires nécessaires nous sommes
en train d'élaborer le calendrier de
publication et nous partagerons avec
vous sans aucune sans aucune
difficulté merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre alors j'ai quatre demandes de
par parole je vais donner la parole tout
de suite à Monique
Lubin merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre il s'agit ici de
transposer un accord national
interprofessionnel sur le partage de la
valeur en entreprise bon qui a été signé
par la quasi totalité des syndicats à
l'exception notable quand même de la de
la CGT si cet accord apporte quelques
amélioration je souhaite quand même en
préambule rappeler le résultat des
travaux sur le sujet de l'ONG
Oxfam qui dénonce le déséquilibre
croissant du partage de la de la valeur
en faveur des actionnaires au détriment
des salariés c'est un
préambule j'ai quelques questions dans
la lettre de cadrage envoyé aux
partenaires sociaux en amont des
négociations de la ni le choix du
gouvernement s'est porté non sur les
discussions sur les salaires mais sur le
partage de la valeur pouvez-vous nous
expliquer les raisons de ce choix a-t-on
une évaluation des dispositif visant à
éviter la substitution des primes et
dispositifs de partage de la valeur ou
salaire et le cas échéant quels ont été
les résultats de ces évaluations
lorsqu'elles ont eu lieu le versement
des primes de partage de la valeur
exonérée de cotisation social présente
le risque d'occasionner un manque à
gagner pour les assurances sociales du
fait de substitution au salaire
avez-vous évalué le montants de ce
manque à gagner et comment
envisagez-vous de le combler le le cas
échéant et j'ai une dernière question il
me semble que cet accord ou alors je je
n'ai pas encore je ne le connais pas
encore parfaitement euh passe quand même
sous silence ne s'intéresse pas beaucoup
aux toutes petites entreprises dans
lesquelles il y a souvent pas de
syndicat et les très petites entreprises
de moins de 10 salariés certaines
d'entre elles ont connu aussi des gains
de productivité certains ces deux ou
trois dernières années et pourtant il me
semble que dans ces très petites
entreprises les employeurs ne se sentent
pas toujours comment dire obligés
d'augmenter les salaire malgré
l'inflation nous avons tous des exemples
concrets donc euh que pouvons-nous faire
pour aussi améliorer le traitement des
salariés dans ces très petites
entreprises
merci très bien je donne la parole à
rayond pourémonge
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
Monsieur le Ministre moi je vais
effectivement euh
appuyer quand même le la préoccupation
la crainte sur les fait de
substitution je rappelle que quand même
ce texte nous est proposé alors que nous
sortons de la contre-réforme des
retraites où le constat était je le
rappelle non que le déficit était dû à
la dynamique des dépenses mais plutôt à
un déficit des ressources dont font
partie les cotisations le deuxième point
c'est que le contexte est aussi celui de
l'inflation hein dont le FMI comm même
estime que 45 % de l'inflation est duû à
la hausse des taux de marge donc à la
boucle prix profit comme disent les
économistes et ce jusqu'à 48 % pour le
secteur de l'agroalimentaire en France
ce double constat donc devrait nous
conduire à effectivement une attention
particulière et urgente je dirais sur
l'évolution des salaires en France pour
ne pas dégrader davantage le partage des
richesses dont vient de parler Monique
Luin et apporter de nouveau nouvelles
ressources à la protection sociale et de
nouveaux droits au
salariés ce ce n'est pas ce qui est
proposé ici alors même que l'effet de
substitution des derniers dispositifs
entre prime exonéré de cotisation
sociale et de prélèvement fiscal et
l'augmentation des salaires est
largement documentée dès à présent on a
quand même un recul depuis la paypa la
prime exceptionnelle de pouvoir d'achat
ça ça a été estimé vous le savez dans
une fourchette cette substitution au
salaire à une évolution qui aurait été
celle des salaires une fourchette de 15
à 40 % et ça a été confirmé avec la PPV
hein la prime de partage de la valeur à
hauteur de 30 % selon l'INC est confirmé
par le conseil de l'analyse économique
aussi monsieur le ministre que
comptez-vous faire pour faire respecter
le principe de non substitution qui est
rappelé dans la loi d'ailleurs grâce à
un amendement de l'Assemblée nationale
j'espère que tout le monde sera d'accord
pour maintenir ce salut salutaire rappel
et si cela vous semble impossible il
serait peut-être temps d'en tirer les
conclusions et de sortir de cette
particularité française qui fait que la
France est un des seuls pays à exempter
intégralement les primes de partage de
la valeur de contribution
sociale de plus quand même dans cet
article dans ce cette loi en détruisant
l'aspect exceptionnel de la PPV vous
acceptez aussi de cannibaliser les
autres dispositifs de partage de la
valeur dont l'intéressement qui au moins
faisait l'objet de négociation
collective là où la PPV relève du bon
vouloir discrétionnaire de l'employeur
et cela aussi est documenté et j'en ai
bientôt fini soyez patient ainsi la
latitude donnée aux entreprises de
choisir le type de dispositif de partage
de la valeur porte le risque de conduire
et c'est la c'est le CEAE de nouveau qui
le documente a une élasticité de
substitution encore plus forte au
détriment des salaires donc que
comptez-vous faire monsieur le ministre
pour réduire ce risque et préserver les
finances de la protection sociale les
finances publiques et aussi les droits
des travailleurs qui sont attachés je
leur appel au salaires socialisés ainsi
escamotés et je termine par dire que le
moyen de contrôle de cet effet de
substitution serait de séparer la
négociation annuelle obligatoire sur les
salaires de celle des dispositifs de
partage de la valeur quel est votre avis
monsieur le ministre sur cette
proposition merci Madame pour pour votre
intervention simplement essayer de ne
pas parler pendant que nous avons un
commissaire qui intervient voilà il y a
un bruit de fond donc par respect
essayez de vous écoutter Olivier
maintenant oui merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre quelques
mots pour saluer cette accord et et pas
bouder notre plaisir on peut pas se dire
attaché au paritarisme au dialogue
social et puis à un moment donné quand
il y a un accord signé par SEP
partenaires sociaux bouder son son
plaisir ça nous donne d'ailleurs une
obligation d'extrême sobriété en terme
d'amendement parce qu'il s'agit pas de
détricoter cet accord à moins d'avoir
une autre vision du dialogue social
saluer même si c'est pas le sujet aussi
l'accord de cette nuit ou d'hier soir
entre les partenaires sur l' agir Carco
hein qui démontre et d'ailleurs là aussi
on aura un regard attentif hein sur la
gestion même de de de de de cette caisse
euh et et ça démontre que le le le
dialogue social ça marche et que le
paritarisme les corps intermédiaires ont
t leur rôle à à jouer dans notre pays
maintenant ma ma question c'est euh quel
champ de négociation pour les
partenaires sociaux quelle est votre
vision sur les champs de négociation des
des partenaires sociaux dans les
semaines et et les mois qui arrivent je
vous remercie merci Monsieur H je donne
la parole à ma Cathy et pouroupouli
merci monsieur le Président alors
Monsieur le Ministre d'abord bonjour
hein euh
voilà
euh moi j'ai j'ai un petit souci
monsieur le ministre on sort d'une
période électorale vous n'êtes pas sans
sans le savoir j'ai je regrette
évidemment que nous n'ayons pas pu
participer aux auditions parce que les
auditions euh nous éclaire et que nous
n'ayons pas pu finalement écouter ceux
et celles qui avaiit des choses à nous
dire puisque ce texte vient tout de
suite au lendemain des élections
sénatoriales et je pense que nous
aurions pu laisser le temps au
commissaire donc des affaires sociales
du Sénat de prendre leur place
véritablement dans ce texte donc un
premier regret euh c'est celui-là mais
euh vous avez choisi de faire autrement
et puis de faire ça à Marge forcée après
la
période après la la période des
retraites qui fut quand même très
difficile après cette période
d'inflation où les familles finalement
ont vu les denrées flamber l'électricité
l'essence enfin j'en passe euh vous nous
proposez aujourd'hui ce texte de loi
alors évidemment prime participation au
bénéfice c'est toujours bon à prendre
dans la période que les Français et les
Françaises vivent c'est toujours bon à
prendre ceci dit vous savez comme moi
que malheureusement les primes ne
comptent pas dans la
retraite que les primes n'amènent pas de
cotisation sociale
supplémentaire intéressement et donc moi
je regrette que finalement il n'y ait
pas une réflexion globale autour autour
des salaires parce que la véritable
question aujourd'hui et on nous dit
souvent que le budget de la Sécurité
sociale va mal qu'il nous faut faire
rentrer finalement de l'argent en plus
et bien la question de l'augmentation
des salaires si elle était posée nous
permettrait
effectivement d'injecter plusieurs
milliards dans les caisses de la
Sécurité sociale et qu'en plus de ça ça
ouvrirait des droits supplémentaires à
la à la à la à la retraite pour
plusieurs salariés alors évidemment il y
a vous le dites cette organisation
syndicale qui ont organisation syndical
et patronal qui ont signé il y a quand
même de grosses organisations syndicales
qui n'ont pas non plus qui n'ont pas
signé une la CGT Monique Lubin l'a dit
elle est pas des moindres oui mais vous
m'excusez voilà elle est pas des
moindres quand même elle compte un peu
vous m'excusez mais la CGT compte un peu
dans le paysage politique bien que ça
vous hein elle compte un peu dans le
paysage français français he et
syndical
donc non mais si vous avez des
réflections à faire vous les ferez à la
fin voilà exaementz terminé chers
collègues terminé
ouais voilà donc moi je regrette que
vous n'ayez pas travaillé la question
des salaires il y aurait beaucoup à dire
mais on va avoir le temps d'en discuter
en en séance plinière Monsieur le
Ministre nous vous ferons des
propositions alternatives parce que une
fois de plus vous ne touchez pas aux
dividendes qui ont été versés aux
actionnaires du CAC 40 80 milliards à
voilà et puis nous aurons une série
d'amendements qui iront dans le sens que
nous souhaitons donc avoir et dans le
débat que nous souhaiterions avoir donc
voilà merci pour terminer je demande
donne la parole à Daniel
Chassin merci monsieur le Président donc
juste quelques mots quand même pour
saluer cet accord national
interprofessionnel hein qui a été signé
par cette organisation syndicale
donc comme ça a été dit donc la loi de
2019 avait permis déjà d'instaurer
effectivement l'intéressement et la
participation et aussi de nouvelles
primes était dit ça 4 milli4 ça faisait
quand même près de 800 €
par de moyenne et les compléments de
rémunération ont rapporté 2400 € par
salarié c'est voilà donc ce projet de
loi je pense on peut dire quand même je
dire fait suite au projet de loi du du
président du général de Gaul qui a été
mis en place en 48 en 56 et 67 et qui
avit défini les fondements du partage de
la valeur que chacun participe
directement en résultat de l'entreprise
donc effectivement comme vous l'avez dit
Monsieur le Ministre ce projet de loi
veut aller plus loin puisque il y a que
vous l'avez dit 6 % d'entreprises de
moins de 50 qui qui applique elles était
d'ailleurs pas obligé donc actuellement
elles devront instaurer un dispositif
effectivement de de partage de la valeur
avec aussi une exonération fiscale et
aussi
l'améliorer l'actionnariat des salariés
et faciliter l'utilisation de la PPV moi
je nous y sommes très favorables même si
effectivement il faut rappeler que la
rémunération ne tient pas de salaire
mais ce texte quand même entérine un
accord d'organisation syndicale et avec
l'objectif d'améliorer le pouvoir
d'achat et donc bien sûr je pense qu'il
faut respecter le travail des
partenaires sociaux et sûrement aider
les très petites entreprises à mettre en
place cet accord merci merci chers
collègues monsieur le ministre je vous
donne la parole pour
répondre merci monsieur le Président
peut-être pour reprendre les quelques
points qui ont été évoqués et qui ont
été évoqués par presque tous les les
intervenants dire qu'effectivement la la
lettre le document d'orientation que
nous avons adressé aux partenaires
sociux en septembre 2022 puisque la
lettre de cadrage j'ai réservé au seul
négociation de la convention de
d'indemnisation de de l'assurance
chômage ce document d'orientation été
concentré sur les questions de partage
de la valeur et non pas sur les
questions salariales pourquoi ce choix
d'abord pour une question très concrète
plutôt très pragmatique si nous avions
installé et et mis dans le champ de
l'accord la question salariale et donc
des questions relatives à l'indexation
ou des augmentations générales je je
pense que nous n'aurions pas d'accord
aujourd'hui parce qu'il n'aurait pas
nécessairement été signé par tous les
partenaires sociaux en tout cas je je
doute que les OP soient entré dans ce
système là la la la deuxième chose c'est
que nous avons considéré c'est la
position que nous défendons depuis
maintenant plusieurs années que la
définition du niveau des salaires dans
dans notre pays passe par l'indexation
du SMIC c'est la loi sur l'inflation au
premier janvier avec des revalorisations
intermédiaires lorsque l'inflation
constatée est supérieure à 2 %
à l'échelle d'un trimestre ou d'une
période pas d'un trimestre pardon mais
d'une période c'est ce qui nous a amené
à cette revalorisation de de 12,6 %
depuis janvier 2021 et cette indexation
a pour conséquence qu'un certain nombre
de conventions Collectiv en matière
salariale voit leur niveau de
rémunération passer en dessous du SMIC
l'obligation de négocier existait avec
une obligation de négocier à 90 jours
que nous avons ramené à 45 jours en
septembre 2022 et et ça marche plutôt
bien ça marche plutôt bien je l'ustre
par un chiffre et je ne dis pas que
c'est toujours par parfitement
satisfaisant mais le 1er mai dernier
avec la dernièreevorisation du SMIC nous
avons constaté que presque 150 146 ou
147 des 170 branches observées avait un
niveau de de un niveau conventionnel au
moins un niveau conventionnel inférieur
au SMIC à l'heure oùù je vous parle et
quand je dis à l'heure où je vous parle
c'est un chiffre de vendredi dernier
nous étions à 60 branches qui n'étaient
pas encore en conformité 60 c'est trop
mais le travail est ouvert dans la
plupart d'entre elles mais ça veut dire
surtout que 85 branches ont fait ce
travail de mise à niveau conventionnel
entre le 1er mai et aujourd'hui et
d'ailleurs il y a un élément qui est
parfois un peu contreintuitif on parle
beaucoup de ces questions de négociation
de branch pour généralement considérer
qu'elle de qu'elle serait trop
apaathique en réalité quand on regarde
sur le temps long le nombre de branches
ayant durablement un niveau
conventionnel inférieur au SMIC et est
moitié inférieur à ce qu'on constate
habituellement sur 15 à 20 ans il est
classique de constater qu'une vingtaine
de branches ont un niveau conventionnel
inférieur auosmic depuis plus d'un an ou
plus 18 mois même aujourd'hui nous
sommes à 7 h branches qui ont un niveau
conventionnel inférieur au SMIC depuis
plus de 18 mois ce qui est plutôt le
signe d' d'une dynamique de négociation
et par ailleurs je le dis mais je pense
que vous l'avez vu vous le savez la les
dispositions adoptées par le Parlement
en juillet 2022 faisant de l'apathie du
dialogue social au sujet des niveaux
conventionnel de rémunération dans une
branche un motif de de restructuration
sont mis en œuvre puisque j'ai adressé à
la Fédération des casinos une un
courrier leur notifiant leur très
prochaine restructuration puisque nous
sommes dans une situation à la fois de
durabilité de la nonconformité mais
aussi de blocage du dialogue social et
donc ça sera la première branche à
expérimenter ce nouveau dispositif ù qui
fait que la restructuration peut-être
euh engagée de manière autoritaire
unilatérale dès lors qu'il y a apatie du
dialogue social en matière de de
rémunération vous avez aussi évoqué la
la question de l'effet de substitution
dire qu'il n'y a aucun effet de
substitution lorsque un dispositif de
prime qui plus avec exonération est mise
en place serait évidemment une
contrevérité il y a quelques difficultés
méthodologiques a été évoqué une étude
remise récemment par le Conseil
d'analyse économique étude qui n'engage
pas le gouvernement je le dis parce que
le CAE étant rattaché administrativement
au Premier ministre il est parfois
considéré comme un organisme dépendant
du gouvernement ça n'est pas le cas et
chaque étude engage la seule
responsabilité de ses auteurs nousous il
est indépendant nous nous considérons
que certaines des hypothèses retenues
par ce rapport ne sont pas
satisfaisantes à nos yeux mais c'est un
débat et nous savons aussi qu'une étude
récente de l'INC donne des résultats
différents et donc en matière
d'évaluation de l'effet substitution
c'est extrêmement difficile puisque des
études extrêmement documentées même si
on peut avoir un débat sur telle ou
telle hypothèse ne donneent pas les les
mêmes résultats quoi qu'il en soit il
faut assurer le contrôle de l'égalité en
matière de prévention d'effet de
substitution et les URSAF euh mène ces
contrôlesl et mène des contrôles qu'on
qualifie globaux pour bien mesurer
entreprise par entreprise lorsqu'il y a
une volonté délibérée de substitution
d'éléments de rémunération et donc de
substitution de prime au salaire je ne
parle pas là des effets mécanique de du
développement des des outils de partage
de la valeur mais bien des cas où dans
certaines entreprises il y a une volonté
délibérée de ne pas de ne pas augmenter
les salaires et de substituer au
salaires des des éléments de prime n
nous ne partageons pas la nécessité
absolue de de dissocier les deux
négociations pour répondre à Madame cons
de manière très directe et nous n'avons
pas retenu d'ailleurs un d'amendement
qui avaient été déposés en ce sens à
l'Assemblée nationale a été évoqué la la
situation des entreprises de moins de 10
salariés c'est une réalité elles ne sont
pas concerné directement par le champ de
l'accord c'est-à-dire que les éléments
de l'accord qui créent des obligations
obligation dispositif de partage après 3
années bénéficiaires à 1 % obligation de
déterminer euh des euh montants
exceptionnel l ce qu'il a résultats
exceptionnels ne sont pas des
obligations pour les entreprises de
moins de 10 salariés c'est d'ailleurs
une des conditions de l'équilibre de
l'accord et et de signature de de cet
accord je je tiens à le préciser ça ne
nous empêche pas d'une part de
développer tous les outils possibles de
de développement de la participation
d'intéressement pour les entreprises de
moins de 10 et je soulligne que derrière
le maintien de l'exonération autour de
la prime de partage de la valeur dans
les entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
il y a aussi cette volonté d'accompagner
les moins de 10 je l'ai dit tout à ce
sont c'est dans les entreprises de moins
de 10 salariés que les montants
individuels de prime de partage de la
valeur ou de prime exceptionnelle de
pouvoir d'achat sont les les plus
importants depuis que nous avons créé
ces dispositifs sur les autres
dispositions les autres interventions
pour répondre à à Madame AP poursopoli
qui m'a dit d'abord bonjour donc
j'allais lui répondre d'abord
félicitations mais je crois que c'est
devenu d'abord au revoir entretemps donc
vous vous lui
transmettrez je je je je réponds
simplement en rappelant la la méthode
qui est la notôre et je sais que sur les
cinq organisations syndicales
représentatives quatre ont signé donc
par définition une n'a pas signé il
n'empêche que le consensus que je
recherche à chaque fois que je donne un
avis favorable à un amendement ou pour
justifier d'un avis défavorable ce qu'il
n'y a pas consensus s'appuie sur les les
SEP organisations pardon madame les avis
favorables à amendement pas souvent oui
mais si je je vous je vous je prends
l'engagement madame la la la sénatrice
que si vous déposez un amendement qui
fait l'objet d'un soutien des SEP
organisations signataire je donnerai un
avis favorable voyez c'est un contexte
un peu différent de ce que l'on connaît
habituellement c'est clair je vous
laisse poursuivre monsieur le ministre
je vous laisse poursuivre et enfin
simplement répondre à la question de
Monsieur ho mais aussi de Madame
ponémonche sur le champ de la
négociation à venir il y a il y a deux
grands blocs de sujets que je peux
porter à votre connaissance le premier
bloc concerne les questions salariales
et notamment la question des bass
salaires
puisque le 16 octobre la veille de
l'examen du texte par votre assemblée
nous réunirons la conférence sociale
annoncée par le président de la
République et qui fait écho à un
engagement que la première ministre
avait pris devant les partenaires
sociaux en juillet sur la question des
des bass salaires et ça va être un champ
de concertation dans un premier temps
extrêmement important et puis nous
préparons un document d'orientation qui
sera adressé aux partenaires sociaux à
la fin du mois d'octobre sur trois
sujets qui sont des sujets très vastes
et et pour lesquels nous souhaitons que
un ou des aénis soi conclus le premier
sujet concerne le compte épargnet
universel le deuxème concerne l'emploi
des seniors avec la possibilité bien sûr
pour la nii de reprendre des élément de
la réforme des retraites qu'on fait
l'objet de censure mais d'aller bien
au-delà en matière d'accompagnement de
l'accès et du maintien dans l'emploi euh
des des seniors et enfin un troisème
sujet sur les parcours professionnels
les carrières et les reconversions ce
sont des sujets très vastes auxquels
nous avons adjoint euh la question des
transitions collectives et des
transitions professionnelles puisque les
dispositifs de transition collective en
particulier sont extrêmement intéressant
ils ont été pensés par les partenaires
sociaux mais ils ont été pensés au début
de la crise covid à un moment où nous
nous attendions les uns et les autres à
des centaines de milliers de
suppressions d'emploi donc avec une
logique très défensive alors qu'il faut
désormais je crois les les simplifier
pour qu'ils soi bien dans une logique
d'accompagnement
des des des transitions collectives et
notamment de la transition numérique ou
encore de la transition environnementale
et et je nous avons dit avec la première
ministre que si des un ou des aénis
étaient conclus sur ces trois grands
sujets nous nous engageons à à déposer
devant le Parlement une loi
transposition avec le même état d'esprit
des transposition fidèles et et
intégrales c'est ce que nous faisons
aussi pour la branche ATMP laani ATMP
puisque dans le cas du PLFSS une
disposition du PLFSS vise à transcrire
dans la loi la disposition de la niatmp
sur la faute inexcusable de l'employur
je le dis parce que j'ai vu ici ou là
quelques réactions récentes disant que
le pfss sur cet aspect-là ne serait pas
bien orienté c'est strict au sensux la
transposition d'un signé lui par les h
organisations représent
tentative très bien merci monsieur le
ministre pour ses réponses donc la suite
des débats en commission présentation du
rapport la semaine prochaine puis en
séance merci beaucoup mes chers
collègues il nous reste encore très
rapidement deux points à l'ordre du jour
ce sont les nomination des
rapporteurs merci
beaucoup